ban ki-moon has been to Russia three
times but this is probably his most
difficult mission he's looking to get
Moscow and the West on the same page on
the issue of Syria the United Nations is
working to end the violence as soon as
possible and transition to a new future
where Syrian people have peace freedom
dignity and justice we agreed and that
negotiated political solution is the
only way to end that crisis so far
Moscow has succeeded in blocking tougher
international sanctions against Damascus
media reports say Russia has also
delivered advanced missiles to Syria but
Moscow has rejected criticism
surrounding its sale of weapons to the
Assad regime you screwed we haven't made
a secret of the fact that we supplied
Syria with arms in accordance with
contracts signed long ago you little
show you cook we haven't violated any
international treaties and these are
primarily defensive systems for now it
appears Russia is sticking by asset an
alliance that could further frustrate
diplomatic efforts to end the fighting
in Syria